à peine réélu est déjà confronté à la
colère populaire depuis dimanche dernier
les manifestations se succèdent en
biélorussie pour protester contre le
sixième mandat d'alexandre loukachenko
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
qui répliquent par des gaz lacrymogènes
des grenades de désencerclement et des
balles en caoutchouc mais pas seulement
ce mercredi la police biélorusse a
annoncé avoir tiré à balles réelles sur
des manifestants qualifié d'agressif
blessant l'un d'entre eux plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont d'ores et déjà
été interpellé arbitrairement selon
leurs familles dont certaines ont dû se
mettre en quête de leurs proches détenus
comme sur ces images prises d'un centre
de détention à minsk devant lequel des
centaines de personnes se sont pressées
à la recherche d'un ami ou d'un parent
ailleurs dans la capitale des dizaines
de femmes vêtues de blanc ont formé une
chaîne humaine pour protester contre les
violences policières
plusieurs manifestations similaires ont
été signalés par les autorités dans tout
le pays
une opposition avec laquelle alexandre
lukashenko ne semble pas disposé à
dialoguer tous ceux qui veulent
travailler qui cherchent à travailler
doivent avoir un emploi et donc un
salaire de ceux qui ne travaillent pas
aujourd'hui devrait faire l'objet d'une
étude au cas par cas et se voir offrir
un emploi un abonnement à ce moment là
que ces soi-disant manifestants sont des
gens qui ont un passé criminel mais qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage et se désole
abobo pas de travail alors va te balader
dans les rues et les avenues
c'est pourquoi je demande et je préviens
gentiment tout le monde
ceux qui ne travaillent pas doivent se
mettre au travail la beauté de son côté
la communauté internationale continue
d'exprimer son inquiétude au cours d'un
entretien téléphonique avec vladimir
poutine et manuellement
on s'est inquiété de la gestion
biélorusse des manifestations même son
de cloche du côté de washington de
berlin ou de l'onu le chef de l'état
fait part de sa très grande
préoccupation sur la situation en
biélorussie et la violence opposés aux
citoyens lors des élections il a
souligné la nécessité de retrouver la
voie du dialogue
nous voulons que le peuple biélorusse
jouissent des libertés qu'ils réclament
il pense être dans son meilleur intérêt
que nous avons observé la manifestation
nous demandons instamment que les
manifestants non violents soient
protégés et ne soit pas blessé
ce n'est dans l'intérêt de personne de
le faire deux dates les gens ont le
droit de s'exprimer et d'exprimer leur
désaccord
a fortiori dans le contexte d'élections
quand les libertés démocratiques devrait
être maintenu et non supprimer le
gouvernement fédéral condamne le recours
à la force contre des manifestants
pacifiques dans les rues de minsk et
ailleurs en biélorussie c'est une vague
de répression qui se déroulent là-bas
avec des milliers d'arrestations après
une élection qui n'était ni juste ni
libre ni veda fait un leurre frei bâle à
toute personne arrêtée en biélorussie
parce qu'elle a manifesté pacifiquement
pour ses droits démocratiques doit être
libérée écouter l'union européenne a
également pris position après avoir
dénoncé mardi un scrutin ni libre ni
équitable ainsi que violences
disproportionnées
bruxelles a annoncé hier avoir convoqué
une réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'ue avec comme réponse
possible
l'instauration de nouvelles sanctions
contre minsk